hallo mein name ist luca um meine lieben
freunde ich darf euch heute recht
herzlich willkommen heißen zu einem
fisch und das bin ich wir sind dieser
kleine süße fisch hier ein gespendeter
dass unser erfreut sich wahrscheinlich
war das dann unser herrchen oder so
falls das überhaupt so heiß beim fisch
und von dem bekommen wir jetzt sogar vor
das finde ich echt ein wahnsinn dass sie
tiere jeden tag das gleiche scheiß
futter essen und die ganze zeit trotzdem
glücklich sind
er vermisst andere fische
das für eine riesenstadt dahinten er
will auf jeden fall raus und check
glaube ich gerade das wenn er gegen das
ding gegen schwimmt das er dann sich
bewegen kann und das heißt da vorne ist
die tür offen dementsprechend wollen wir
glaube ich mit dem kleinen fische
abhauen falls ich das jetzt richtig
verstanden habe also hier sind wir wir
hören auch
eine uhr
das wird wahrscheinlich die da hinten
seien auf jeden fall wollen die dort
hingehen aber ins wasser auch wir haben
sogar menschen hier am start mal schauen
ob wir hier direkt runter können da
haben wir nämlich erstmal unser essen
weg und sind sagt
[Musik]
ich glaube
ich bin noch nie so schnell in einem
spiel gestorben hier geht's auf jeden
fall nicht lang von daher sollten wir
glaube ich mal diesen weg hier vorne
probieren dass ich da sehr süßen kleinen
stadt aus hier erinnert mich ein
bisschen an san francisco der andere
wird sich jetzt wahrscheinlich auch
fragen luca du hast doch in deinem
letzten mal traf wie du gesagt hast du
heute page im simulator spielen willst
also ein tauben simulator
sie können gar nicht bremsen so erstmal
ganz
oder sie echt ein bisschen traurig aus
ich habe euch eigentlich versprochen
dass ich sie
habe es aber geschafft
das ist alles fischfutter wir haben hier
vorne sogar ein aquarium wir wollen aber
raus und daher ab in richtung ausgang ja
was ich sagen wollte war dass ich
eigentlich den tauben sind heute spielen
wollte den gibt es allerdings nicht mehr
wohin die von steam runtergenommen also
von diesem spieleplattform hersteller
situation
wir haben diesen draußen
ich glaube das sollte wirklich san
francisco seien und dass davon dass die
golden gate bridge die zwar nicht so
golden ist aber die normale golden gate
bridge ist auch nicht gold die ist rot
wir können hier lang glaube ich über das
geländer darüber marco denn da müssen
wir nur aufpassen dass wir das irgendwie
hier alles halten können wir unser fisch
wird die ganze zeit herum geschleudert
war schon mein gott er das unter glas
oder nicht kaputt gegangen ist hier
vorne müssen wir noch dass ich tief mit
einsammeln aber wie gerade bereits
gesagt eigentlich wollte den tauben
simulator spielen doch jetzt spielen wir
in fisch simulator es war ja auch ganz
cool er war mir dann als nächstes lang
nach vorne es noch so ein seil aber das
ist nicht zweigleisig und da oben kommen
wir auch nicht hoch glaube ich hier
können wir lang also ab nach rechts
kleiner fische wir brauchen auch einen
namen für den nemo wert zu einfallslos
wenn ihnen einfach nie da war sandra
auch stolz dass ihr lieblingsrapper also
rüber aufs andere häuschen da unten
haben wir leute rum chillen wir haben
leute die dort warten unser fisch fast
komplett aus in diesem glas und jetzt
hier lang hier ist der nächste check
ballacks ist es anscheinend wirklich so
ein kleines jump n run spiel wir laufen
jetzt mal hier vorne lang wahrscheinlich
laufen mir luca keine ahnung ob wir
diese europalette hier hochkommen nicht
tun wir nicht die legte aber ja auch
nicht ohne grund oder also irgendwie
müssen wir da erlangen oder kann man
hier irgendwie runter oder so hier geht
es lang hier wird zwei mäßig das heißt
wir können uns theoretisch probieren
hierüber aber okay wir haben es
geschafft also da lang da ist nämlich
direkt das nächste teil ich weiß nicht
ob wir wirklich ins meer müssen oder ob
ich mich gerade ein bisschen verlaufe
oder ob es noch mehr möglichkeiten
gebracht haben
ich schaue ob ich hier irgendwie lang
kommen weil auf das teil komme ich ja
nicht mehr drauf zu bilden das bremsen
nemo anymore hier aus nach oben dann an
der gießkanne natürlich dran vorbei
lustig war ich wollte früher immer in
gold verschaffen und genauso in seinem
glas und dass man so weitergeht dann ist
ja da aber das ist jetzt ein goldfisch
total scheiße das hat mir dann meine
eltern gesagt aber ich habe dann auch
jetzt irgendwann erfahren dass zumindest
das bei quallen so ist dass man eine
qualle wirklich ohne das ist
tierquälerei ist kann man eine qualle
einfach weil ich behalten wir müssen
runter nehmen perfekt hier vorne wartet
was is das ne pfeife oder so neben brot
okay wir haben gut bekommen bei quallen
ist es so die checken das gar nicht
deren verstand geht irgendwie nur 10
sekunden oder so da die können überhaupt
nicht nachdenken deswegen ist es für
eine qualle völlig normal wenn sie in so
einem kleinen glas schön würde weil sie
wird das eh nicht checken deswegen ist
das keine tierquälerei aber ich glaube
bei dem fisch ist das noch mal ein
bisschen was anderes also jetzt mal
erstmal hier die dachrinne lange jetzt
müssen ein bisschen langsam hier machen
nemo einmal ganz kurz hier nach vorn ein
bisschen schneller müssen wir schon
seiner und ist auch schon das mehr als
wir haben es gleich eventuell sogar
schon geschafft sagt rein hier hier
nochmal runter vollspeed car oder unten
hin es ist süß gemacht das ganze spiel
also mit den ganzen leuten die
herumlaufen und mit den autos die da
unten rechts ranfahren und so ist ein
kleiner ferienort hier glaube ich aber
wir müssen weiter hier vorne und werden
dann hoffentlich jetzt gleich auch
gebremst von den teilen
hier müssen noch immer in richtung mehr
und das meer ist dort unten aber wie
kommen wir denn jetzt da oben hoch dann
müssen wir eben hier von uns auch noch
einen weg ein kleiner das sollten wir
auch hinkriegen dann haben wir erstmal
diese papp die runde nein das geht nicht
das geht nicht niveau zurück zurück
zurück jetzt hier rechts lang und dann
hier rechts ganz langsam runter
okay wir haben es geschafft ich denke
mir jedes mal wenn wir allerdings drauf
sind und man das meer ein bisschen
genauer sieht dass man ja jeden moment
da sein müsste aber ich glaube es dauert
noch ein kleiner moment ein oder nein
ich habe es geschafft bremsen so ok sehr
gut hier vorne den checkpoint okay dann
haben gerade eingesammelt da geht's
nicht weiter oder geht es hier weiter
es geht auf jeden fall so aus welche so
ein kleiner weg ist aber ich glaube da
würden wir nur wieder runter fallen
hier geht's nicht lang wir müssen halt
irgendwie noch mal so einen weg runter
finden aber ich weiß nicht wo lang das
eventuell sein gehen könnte den sekunden
später
vielleicht hier
ok ich probier's mal hier vorne an der
gießkanne dran vorbei vielleicht haben
wir noch in wk da haben wir eine kleine
dingsda kann ich jetzt nehme ich mal
ganz kurz hier an der seite kommen nemo
bisschen gas hier das ist
es heißt nicht dein ernst dicker
ok müssen wir den anderen weg suchen die
sache ist nur es gibt keine von diesen
doppelten teilen hier mehr doch da
hinten sind auf welche aber dann haben
wir glaube ich den falschen weg genommen
beziehungsweise müssen rüber auf das
andere dach aber es gab ja nichts
anderes oder müssen wir hier vielleicht
über die steine drüber so ein bisschen
als ansprung ort näher
war hier dann ging es doch auch nicht
oder einen tag später hier vorne muss es
ja irgendwie lang gehen wenn das hier
extra offen gemacht wurde ach so ach so
wir können einfach auf die auf die
terrasse da drauf haben wir auf die
markise ach so da hätte ich auch selbst
aufkommen können jetzt sind wir hier auf
jeden fall unten können uns glaube ich
ein bisschen umgesehen in der stadt das
will ich aber ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
ich möchte mich direkt ins meer ich will
dass unser kleiner nino zu den anderen
fischen rüberkommt als einmal ganz kurz
das stuhlbein mitnehmen perfekt und
jetzt aber voll karacho nach vorne alter
jemand
bildete jetzt hier
so
da kommen jetzt nicht lange oder wie ich
habe allerdings einen plan freunde ich
weiß jetzt klappen wir brauchen eine
menge an schwung und jetzt erst einen
tisch bringt und
[Musik]
schwimmen jetzt einfach direkt von
beginn an schon ein bisschen weiter und
jetzt auch früher
ich kann auch einfach hier ins wasser
fällt man auf oder ich muss gar nicht
den steg daran wer braucht denn stegner
hier
[Musik]
drei sterne
und wir haben 80
558 leben haben wir dafür gebraucht an
der stelle wird das heutige video ist
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn euch dieses kurze kleine
knackige video hier zwischendurch
gefallen hat mit nino unserem kleinen
fischen hier vor lassen einen darunter
video abonniert main kanal und klickt
auf die glocke wenn ihr andere neue
videos nicht verpassen wollt übermorgen
um 20 uhr kommt eine neue minecraft
episode wenn ihr die letzte folge noch
nicht gesehen ab wie viel die jetzt hier
am rand eingeblendet also schaut sie
euch gerne an und mimot hasse dich weil
du mich 58 mal gekillt hast aber folgt
leser luca auf instagram so
laser luca